par le nombre ils mettent une projet ici
maradona
[Musique]
les drass
mon ami
est-ce que ça va
lâcher son couteau
bonsoir capitaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous attaquent abandonner le navire
[Musique]
peut-être
je te tiens tu vois bien fait faillite m
je veux dire mais qu'est ce qui se passe
pirate
pirates
non des savants oui nous aimons vieux
savant nous l'assuré on en mange
mélanger des produits jouer avec des
éprouvettes et des brûlures entre elles
voyez
n'est pas scientifique c'est une
éclaireuses
ce n'est pas une éclaireuses c'est un
malentendu
[Musique]
autre magistrat
le dodo si vous lui couper la tête nous
ne serons jamais ou
quidam
nous ignorons pourquoi peut être est ce
à cause de sa barbe luxuriante de ces
deux états ce land ou parce qu'ils
dégagent une légère odeur de noix de
coco mais nous sommes empêchés de ce
pilote vous avez un an capitaine pirate
on m'appelle le capitaine pirate eh bien
cher capitaine pirate vous êtes
désormais pardonner de la totalité de
créer
[Applaudissements]
pour restaurer à londres mon cher
capitaine divertir et grâce à vos
histoires et votre esprit sans oublier
évidemment ou votre attachement petit
autant
tiens tiens si ce n'est pas le capitaine
pirate
ou revoilà la roma fois et vous monsieur
darwin cachés sous ses plumes
mais que voilà une agréable visite
surprise vous avez avant j'étais trop
timide pour l'avouer
mais je suis amoureuse de vos charges
diantre
c'est vrai
non
moi
alors vous qui soyez raisonnable vous
une toute petite reine contre moi la
mythique terreur des autres paires
regarde
pauvre petit mois
que puis-je contre normes comme vous
[Musique]
calmez vous
attention
baptiste
complexe de la berd s'est passé vous
êtes sauf sol est de dinosaures et son
côté romantique
[Musique]
aux
missions
[Musique]
devraient plus exister
votre nez à voler
[Musique]
dommage que les pirates ne se marche
mais vous auriez probablement un goy
faict de barnak tandis que votre cher
paul est sera je m'arrête pas
[Musique]
su bobo
a tapé sur google
désolé mais qui le dodo est retiré du
menu
[Musique]
bah
oh
à
viens jouer série numéro 2 qu'est ce que
tu fais aussi comment vas tu retrouvé où
sont les autres
oui
[Musique]
monnet
paquet
capitaine
et adieu votre chère petite amie en
belgique
[Musique]
sa
mort
baleines à bosse
[Applaudissements]
jouer capitale
[Musique]
mon chapeau
c'est assurément la plus surprenante est
attendrissante de toutes nos aventures
mais l'énergie côté nous avons compris
la fête oui à charger et dans un salon
est là pour vous dire que votre pardon
le dia plus
recherchés aux quatre coins de la
matraque
plus nationalement de galles antoine
veyrat
[Musique]
bienvenue à bord
capitaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]